BARTON ZWIEBACH:
Hydrogen atom is
the beginning of our analysis.
It still won't solve
differential equations,
but we will now two particles,
a proton, whose coordinates are
going to be coordinate
of the proton,
subbing Xp for the proton,
and momentum of the proton.
And there's an electron.
And there's the coordinates,
the three coordinates
of the electron, and
the three components
of the momenta of the electron.
And these are your
canonical variables.
This means that the
components of this object
satisfy the standard
commutation relations.
That is-- I have to write
it like the following.
They considered the
coordinates of the proton,
the i-th component.
And the momentum of the proton,
the j-th component, that's
equal to ih bar delta ij.
You see, we used to code for
its x, y, and z, and momenta
Px, Py, Pz.
You could've called it X1,
X2, X3, momenta P1, P2, P3.
And in that way, you can use
a parameter delta over here.
So, these are the
commutation relations
of X's and P's, but
X and P for a proton.
So, the proton has
its X, has its P,
and it behaves like an X
and P that we've studied.
The electron has its X, its P,
and also behaves the same way
as coordinates P of electron
j equal ih bar delta ij.
You see, this is
because x operator, y
operator, z operator--
you can call them
xi operators with 1, 2, 3.
The Px, Py, Pz operators
are better called P sub i,
with i running from 1, 2,
and 3, and x being the first,
y the second, z being the last.
Then the fact that the x
just fails to commute with Px
and y fails to commute with
Py, and z fails to commute
with Pz is xi pj
equal ih bar delta ij.
And this is what I'm saying
here with this notation
because there are
too many subscripts.
There's a P for
proton, but there's
an i for the first, second
and third component.
And there's the
momentum of proton,
which has 1, 2, 3 components.
So, those are our
dynamical variables.
And then when you
try to solve this,
you have the issue
of wave functions.
What happens to
the wave functions?
Should I invent a wave function
for the electron and a wave
function for the proton?
No.
That's not good.
You shouldn't a wave
function for everybody,
which is a wave function that
depends on the coordinates
X of the electron.
And if you had just
an electron, you
would have a wave function that
depends on X of the electron
and a wave function that
depends on the coordinates
of the proton.
And how would you normalize it?
Well, this thing times
d cubed Xe times d
cubed Xp is the
probability, dP to find
the electron around the little
cube about the point, Xe,
and the proton around the
little cube around Xp.
And then if you
want to see what is
it probability to find
the electron at some point
regardless of the proton,
you integrate over
the whole proton.
And then you should just
have a wave function.
So, if you integrate this
psi squared-- oh, I'm sorry,
psi is squared.
If you this psi squared
over the proton,
you're left with
some probability
density for the electron.
So, this is the good thing about
having more and more particles.
You still have just one wave
function and one Schrodinger
equation.
You have more particles, and
it's just one wave function.
That's why people eventually
talk about the wave
function of the universe.
I say, well, the whole
universe has one wave function
for every, for every molecule,
for every elementary particle.
There's just one wave function.
That's nice about the
Schrodinger equation.
And, OK, so we have this,
and what is the Hamiltonian?
The Hamiltonian is
the kinetic energy
associated to the proton plus
the kinetic energy associated
to the electron plus the
potential energy, which
just the depends on the
distance between the electron
and the proton.
And then and write the
differential equation,
the Schrodinger equation.
And the P of the proton would
be thought as ddx of the proton.
And the P of the electron would
be like ddx of the electron.
And that differential
equation would make sense.
So what is our problem
showing that we have--
can think in some way as a
potential or a Schrodinger
equation that the most--
just some distance that
separates the particles, and
some equation for the rest.
So, we have to change variables.
So what is the
change of variables?
I'm going to motivate
some of that.
Well, we have two pairs
of canonical variables.
We have the proton canonical
variables, X and P,
of the proton, and the electron
canonical variables, X and P,
of the electron.
So how can we have
different kind
of variables that will lead
to a more interesting thing?
We can imagine that maybe we
should define a new X that
is the difference for which
the magnitude of that X
will be what we call r.
And that's true, but it's
not so easy to do that
from the beginning, so let's
try to do what most people would
do from experience
and say, I know
there's something simple about
a system of doing the wrapping
values, center of mass.
If the center of mass moves
with constant velocity,
that's what it does always.
So, if classical notions of
how you treat two-body systems
can be used in a
quantum setting,
we should be able to
define a new quantum
coordinate associated
to the center of mass,
and a new quantum
momentum associated
to the center of mass.
And the center of mass
momentum is always
the sum of the momenta, so we
will define at P, a capital P--
I hope that my P's are
going to be always clear.
They're not supposed to have
before this one, the little bar
below.
This is the total,
P, and it's going
to be defined as the momentum
of the proton plus the momentum
of the electrons.
And now, I want to define
an X that goes with this P.
And by that, I mean that this
X must have a commutation
relation with this P
that tells, yes, you
are an X because X with
P should be ih bar.
So, whatever I define
here, that should happen.
Now, you could imagine
that we usually
do something like this--
we multiply each particle
according to its mass.
Pe.
So we're weighting the
momenta associated to--
oh, I'm sorry.
The positions, Xp, Xe,
associated to the mass.
And this, of course, would
not have the right units.
It doesn't have
units of coordinate,
so this is the center of mass.
So, this will be center
of mass quantum variables.
And in order to have units,
you must divide by a mass,
so it's not too unreasonable
to put the sum of masses here.
That's how you define it
anyway in classical mechanics.
And now, we must ask is X
with P the i-th component
of the j-th component.
Is it really equal
to ih bar delta ij?
And the answer, I
would say, is yes
because, here,
let's do this one.
You will have mp Xpi plus
me Xei over mp plus m e.
You see, once you
do one, all the rest
you should be able to do
just without thinking.
P, on the other hand, is
P of the momentums of j
plus the momentum of
the electron, so j.
What is it equal to?
And then you say, look,
from Xp with momentums of P,
yes, they give me ih bar delta
ij, but there will be ih bar.
The first factor there will be
an extra mp over mp plus m e.
So this contribution comes from
the first term that only talks
to the momentum of the proton.
Doesn't talk to the
momentum of the electron.
And the second term for the
coordinate of the electron
only talks to the
momentum of the electron.
And it does give you
an ih bar delta ij,
but this time will be with
an m e over mp plus m e.
And this factor is equal to 1.
So, yes, we can box this.
This is a pair of quantum
mechanical canonical variables.
They have the right commutation.
They have the right units,
the right commutator,
the right everything.
So next time when you
see this, you will say,
X with P-- you say,
Xp with P is 1.
Xe with P is 1.
mp plus-- 1.
Yes, it works.
You forget ih bar delta ij.
This is more clear
that it will work.
Try it.
Next, we need the second pair
of canonical variables, so--
well, actually I should
use this one for this.
So for the second pair,
it's reasonable to use the X
that we anticipated, so we'll
have a relative coordinate, X.
And I don't know how I call it--
X relative, or--
no, just little x.
Little x will be defined
as X of the electron.
I think that's coordinates.
X of the electron
minus X of the proton.
This is natural.
We want a little x like that.
Already at this point, you
could be paralyzed with fear.
Something could have gone
wrong at this moment.
Imagine if this x doesn't
commute with these guys.
Then it's all a
disaster because this
should be electron and proton
commute with each other.
I should have written
there, not only
those are the
commutation relations,
everything else is 0.
Any X of electron with a
momentum of a proton is 0.
That's why they're
two independent pairs
of canonical variables
that we can treat.
It better be that this
is an independent pair
of canonical
variables, so it better
be that this x and whatever
P I'm going to define here
commute with these guys.
And as far as this x,
happily it works out
because X's commute
with any X's here,
so this little x definitely
commutes with the little x.
But the fact that this commutes
with P could have killed it,
but it doesn't because
of the minus sign.
One of the commutators of the
little x with the capital P
would give for the electron
an ih bar, and for the proton,
a minus ih bar.
And they cancel.
So, all is good so far.
So, this is so far so good--
commutes with capital X
and capital P. So now,
we have here something,
and we could put that
number, alpha Pe minus beta
P of the proton.
And we all know what
alpha and beta are.
But now you can more
or less be confident.
I need that this momentum
with this x give me 1, ih bar.
So, that would put the
condition on alpha and beta.
In fact, the condition
that xi with P bar j
give you ih bar delta ij,
you can imagine what it is.
It's that alpha plus
beta is equal to 1.
And the condition
that this momentum
commute with the center
of mass position, which
it can fail to do so--
what can it give?
Well, W alpha of the P of
the electron goes with m e,
so it's something like alpha m
e minus beta mp is equal to 0.
And please-- oh, this
commutator should be 0.
Please make sure you
know how to do this.
You can get those conditions.
I'm going maybe a little fast
for you to just follow it up.
And so, at this moment, we
can solve for alpha and beta--
two equations.
So alpha is equal to
mp over me plus mp.
And beta is equal to
m e over m e plus mp.
And we have a pair of
canonical variables
as well here, therefore,
the relative coordinate
and the relative
momentum, in some sense.
It's useful to
define two symbols.
So, we use mass m e
mp over mp plus mp.
And the total mass,
which is m e plus mp.
In the case of a heavy proton,
the reduced mass-- the proton
is heavy compared
with the electron.
You can ignore the electron
here, cancel them, e.
And the reduced
mass is called this.
So, in terms of
the reduced mass,
alpha is equal to mu over m
e, and beta is mu over mp.
Those are unit-free constants.
So summarizing, the second
pair of canonical variables
are Xe minus--
Xe minus Xp.
And P equals mu Pe over m
e minus P sub p over mp.
All right, so--
so, the last step
that we're going to follow,
and after that, we'll
get the Hamiltonian
and stop there.
And we'll discuss
solutions next time.
But finally, we have
enough equations
to solve for the momenta
we have in the Hamiltonian
in terms of the
center of mass momenta
and the relative momenta.
So, from equation
star and double star
here, you can solve
for these momenta.
So, P of the proton will be
equal to mp over M, big momenta
minus little momenta.
And P of the electron is m e
over capital M, big momenta
plus little momenta.
Well, one more equation
that we have to write,
and that's the key
to the simplicity
of all what we've done.
At this moment, we have a
very good physical insight
into what we've
done, but we want
to see if the math collaborates.
And the good
physical insight has
been that center of
mass motion should
be independent of
the relative motion,
and of we have the right X.
So, the thing that
we have to compute
is the first two terms
in the Hamiltonian,
P of the proton squared
over 2m of the proton
plus p of the electron squared
over 2 mass of the electron.
So, I have 1 over
2m of the proton,
and I have m of the proton over
capital M, P minus little p,
and plus 1 over 2m
of the electron--
this is squared--
m of the electron
over capital M, big
P plus little p.
And the plus and minus
are extremely reassuring
because the cross terms
that couple the two
are going to vanish.
You can see cross terms will
have a minus sign. mp will
be canceled.
m e will cancel.
They will cancel.
So at the end of this
little calculation that
takes couple of lines, you get
1 over 2 capital M total center
of mass of this squared plus
1 over 2 mu little momentum
squared.
This is a kinetic operator.
And then you say, great
success, the kinetic energy
now has separated into a
center of mass contribution
and a relative contribution.
This will allow us to
now with a little step,
separate the total Schrodinger
equation into center
of mass motion and
relative motion,
and the relative motion will
have [INAUDIBLE] potential.
So we'll do the
punchline next time.